hi
everyone i hope you enjoyed the
conference so far
my name is zainab i'm a senior data
scientist at tomtom and a proud
committee member
of pi data eindhoven i'm here
in the studio together with my co-host
dimitra
she's a data scientist at asml and she's
going to support us
remotely from home and we are kicking
off the afternoon session with a special
uh q a with corinne vigro
i know most of you uh may know corey but
for a proper introduction to her she is
a co-founder of tomtom
and founder of kodam a free programming
school in
in amsterdam she is an amazing role
model and a successful woman in tech
and as pi data committee we are so proud
to have her
here in the event within the next 25
30 minutes we are going to chat about
her journey to
uh the tech world kodam
future of education and open source
please do use the q a chat box to
put your questions there we try our best
to answer all your questions
but let's uh start with corrine hello
corinne
thank you so much for joining we are
happy to have you here
well thank you very much for inviting me
every time i can fly
the women in technology flag you know
i'm very happy to be able to do that
we are so excited to have you here so as
i think as a first
and i think natural questions and
something that we are all wondering
you have co-founded tomtom 30 years ago
what how did you get to where you are
here please take us to your journey
right i'll do that quickly because you
know 30 years a very very long time i
know i don't like it
it's a long time so i started in i come
from a little suburb outside leo and
some of my friends started a games
company that
was called infogram that became um to be
atari later on
and i started there within a week they
sent me to london
and i arrived in london in 86 and tech
was booming
in the computer game industry and that's
kind of how i fell
into it um fast forward a few years
later i joined a company called scion
and
in 87 and scion was the precursor of
you can imagine the beginning of the
mobile phones without data connectivity
they were doing handheld computers
so you could do a lot of things in the
palm of your hand joined that company
and i just got the bug
tech is about innovating it's about
solving problems it's about going fast
making decisions having
impact and when a few years later i had
the opportunity to join a more
traditional company which i did when i
moved to holland
i only stayed for six months because i
missed
that uh what technology that vibe that i
had seen
both at infogram and then at scion
so after six months in a more
traditional industry um
i decided that i needed to get back into
technology
and i joined a couple of guys who were
making some software for those
famous handheld computer and so uh
where's tomtom started
it was called palm top software
and that was in 92 um
and at the beginning we were just doing
software we were we were doing software
for those handheld computers you can
imagine 92
no you know no windows no uh
in terms of microsoft windows um there
was uh
still internet was in its infancy there
was no
email there was everything was very very
uh early on in
the process and we our role was to put
uh computers in the hand of blue color
workers who were doing meter reading
application
so we were very good at making uh user
interface very simple
and that's how we started we made
broader application
and in 95 we came across a navigation
product
for the pc and we said well that's weird
why would you want to have navigation on
your pc
you want navigation in your car that's
when you need it otherwise you need to
print it you need to take in your car
what happens if you missed a term of
course it wasn't ideal
so imagine if we could program our
little devices
with navigation everybody told us it was
not possible you can imagine at the time
the maximum memory we had was
uh 256k and then 512
you know that was what we had available
we didn't have a one megabyte
uh nothing would fit on it so we became
known for how good we could compress
data and uh and the rest is history we
we started making software for those
handheld computers and we could see that
even so it wasn't uh you needed to
download the city at the time
you only had roots between big cities
this was overselling anything else we
were doing in terms of software so we
said hey
we don't do something this is solving a
problem why don't we push this
further and put everything in one box
and
the the the brief we gave the developers
as you buy that box in
the shops you put it in your car and you
navigate home
no need to connect it to a computer we
wanted to make it really easy
technology in in the hands of people who
don't understand technology
but that still solve a real purpose and
we sold from zero to one million we went
faster than a mobile phone that meant
also that
the need for this type of device was was
huge and
that's where the company really started
going and growing really fast so between
92
and 2004 we were hovering between 40 and
50 people
and then we went from 40 million
turnover to 1.8 billion and
you know there was no stopping us it was
a whole other story but uh
but that's a journey so it's a journey
of starting in
in the computer games industry in
falling completely in love with
technology
uh for a long time i was the only woman
but i didn't even notice we were we were
teamed together we were
kind of making changing the world a
little bit uh there was a huge amount of
energy
and uh and here we are fast forward uh
2020 and then yeah tomtom is still uh
having a big impact so i'm very proud of
that
well that's so inspiring i think i've
heard the story from different people
you know how
tom tom started and how how we get here
but it's always inspiring to hear it
from you
so you have over these years you have
seen several companies how
they have changed and how this tech
world has has been changing
and uh so my next question for you is
that what do you think in your opinion
is the biggest
challenge that the tech companies are
facing right now and they take for
the tech world is facing right now i
think
there's quite a few to be honest first
of all
as an european tech leader i couldn't
tell you that i was
not worried about the dominance in
technology
from people on either side of us
namely the america and asia
technology is everywhere it's everywhere
in the way we interact it's everywhere
and the way we consume news
it's everywhere and i think the the
what's important is uh
technology sometimes has a bad name
people are saying well it's gonna
it's gonna take jobs well actually i
think it creates a lot of new
opportunities
uh people are saying but it's doing bad
things but actually it's doing a lot of
good stuff
you look at the at the use of of new
technology and
uh if you look at ai and the the impact
it will have in mobility
in in medicine of course it has some
potential negative side but there's so
many good
that can be taken out of it we just need
to make sure it's done the proper way
what worries me is when you write the
future
when you're in technology that cannot be
one type of people who write that future
so i am concerned
about the fact that it's a still a very
male dominated environment
and i'd like to see many more type of
diversity and i mean of course gender
diversity but
cultural diversity uh socio-economic
diversity
the world of tomorrow is being written
as we speak
and we need a big diverse group to do
that
so i think technology is the force for
good
uh it needs to be we need to have rules
and regulations like we've had for years
everywhere else to make sure
that uh the power of technology is not
being abused and i think governments can
do that and you see that
the regulators is jumping onto that with
the gdpr that we have
in europe there are a minimum of of
framework we need to operate
but the the power of technology of
solving a lot of our
daily problem is huge and i have a big
appeal for making europe
bigger so we can really also play a role
if you're not
if you're not at the table you're on the
menu and that's we don't want to be used
in europe as well
uh we want to be an active player and
and
it's nice to see a lot of actually
fintech company doing well in europe we
need to have
a broader range of technology company
being active
and i want much more diversity
well and you actually mentioned one of
the things that i'm personally
passionate about and i care about
about gender diversity so it's no secret
that we don't have enough women in tech
but what do you think are going to be
active steps to change this
well i think what you're doing zen up
today will change things
the fact that you're there on stage that
you explain what you're doing
that you are you give other women a
platform
that makes a difference you yeah you
want to see what you want to become and
i think it is important that that
all of us women in technology and there
are many have got many
uh women friends that uh all over europe
that are
playing big rules in technology they're
being recognized by forbes or
inspiring 50. so we we need to have a
voice and that is the reason why when
you asked me to speak
i said yes just to show that it's it is
a
it is a fun world um also the
the idea that technology is uh you know
you need to be good at math and you need
well
in data science it's better if you're
good at math and statistics but
in in technology in general in in
encoding in software engineering
you just need to be creative and i think
technology is open to to everyone and if
you look at the profile i have at kodam
i've got people who studied art history
or studied music
so it's a very diverse group of people
so back to your question
how do we make this more appealing
first of all we open the pandora box of
stereotypes
it is not what people think it is we
need to educate
the public young students even
early students when they are teenagers
about how much
impact they can have especially girls
and boys but
girls as well the impact they can have
the fact that the jobs that will be
created
by the tech world will give them a nice
source of income and they can do
something that's meaningful to them they
can work on climate change they can work
on energy
they can work on transport they can work
in a medical field
there's so many fields so what i think
we need to do is
is get women to speak um they're
everywhere
you know them they are taunton as well
it's uh we just need to give them a
platform we just need to make sure
they are confident enough to go and
speak and that's what we do at kodam
we bring a lot of women speakers either
in cyber security or
in their field of interest um what i
like about women in technology is
women we tend i don't want to stereotype
but when we do something we we tend to
want to have impact we tend to want to
uh change things for the better we want
to create a better world for our
children
i'm not saying men don't want that but i
think us as women as mothers we probably
want that more than anyone
if you combine that they give us the
tools and the means to actually do it
through technology
that's immensely powerful and that's
what i think that women who are working
in those fields who are having this type
of impact
you probably saw last night the nobel
prize that was given to two women for
the first time with their discovery
in uh for in medicine so i think
we're getting there bit by bit and we
should
look through our organization our
companies
and make sure we pull all those women
that sometimes are working
silently because you know they don't
have the confidence to step up
and say look you could be someone like
that
and you could have a lot of fun in the
process
yeah i completely agree with you i think
we should create the community that
makes
that empowers all people from
underrepresented groups women
to to be confident to step up and take
this stage
yeah i completely agree with you you uh
you mentioned kodam and uh
i i think most of us who are um now
doing the programming
we learned a programming language either
as a course
uh in the university or college or
self-training
so i don't remember i've i've never
heard of any uh dedicated programming
school what was the reason that you
started
codem and how its educational philosophy
is different from
regular education
well actually in in 2005 it all started
was a long journey
i set up a foundation which was aimed at
at equal opportunity and education i
wanted to to mix the two
so for a long time i look at
associations and ngos that were working
in this field so basically combining
education and equal opportunities and i
came across
the 42 school in paris that was set up
by xavier who is a big telecom
entrepreneurs in france
and what struck me in that school was
that
you could anybody could get there you
you it didn't matter what you had done
before i mean you know
as teenagers and especially in today's
world with the pressure and
the environment sometimes young people
just
get off the rail 14 15
but in our current education system if
that happens
it's written you you cannot it's very
difficult to then go to university and
in holland if you haven't done favorio
it's it is difficult if you haven't done
that then you can do
abeo and go back but it doesn't it's not
easy to to if you're gonna it doesn't
mean you're stupid
it doesn't mean you're not ambitions it
just means that
at that age the stars were not aligned
or you had to face something so
i i'm very worried that the current
education system
is a bit too rigid for the current world
we live in that was one
number two is um i could see a lot of
kids who also didn't didn't manage to
to exploit or to maximize their
potential
because they were not coming from the
right areas because they didn't have
access to university because they didn't
know what they wanted to do existed
and what i like about 42 is you could go
in you just needed to do the online test
and i didn't care what you had done
before the other thing is
i know that software engineers are in
big demand
you can see at some time how difficult
it is for us to recruit
we tend to go and put offices next to
university that's why we started offices
in poland and
in belgrade and so i said well that's
crazy because we've got all those kids
that fall off the bandwagon that are
you know have a lot of potential at the
same time we've got a big gap in
software engineering and coders
uh we need them because we we the world
software is ruling the world
and xavier put the two together and he
had created this school
where basically uh anybody could get in
and you could learn to program
and what i liked about it there was
peer-to-peer learning so you were
learning to learn
and you know you you it's not about
which programming language you're
learning is
where you find the information to solve
the problems software
engineering is about solving a problem
and you also know that there are various
ways of doing that
and that's cool actually you needed to
learn from each other
and you needed to learn to learn and
that learned to learn that soft skills
is the most
important soft skills for the future the
world is going at such a pace
then we all have to keep learning as i
told you the beginning of my journey i
think the first time i saw computer
was the commodore 64 of my brother when
i was 20 and i
cassette tapes can you imagine all the
way where we are now talking about
you know machine learning and deep
learning and using all this uh
technology to uh to do a computer vision
and our maps
i had to learn i had to keep learning
i'm not saying i'm going to be a big
uh ml engineers tomorrow but at least i
understand
the basics and the fundamentals so for
all my career i've had to keep learning
and i think having
encouraging students early on to be
curious to
keep learning to understand and indeed
to adapt to the world
that's very important so that school was
ticking all the boxes
it was open to everyone it will form
software engineers which the world need
desperately
and therefore give people a chance to
participate in in the economic progress
of society and they was insisting on the
soft skills that are so
important to anyone so i contacted them
i said look i'd love to do this in
holland
can you give me a license to your
curriculum and
it looks like i wasn't the only one
because now you have 34 school in the
network
sponsored by various uh organizations
like the telefonica foundation in spain
uh like um who is the the founder of
supercell in
in finland so other entrepreneurs or
foundation that
are focused on education have basically
bought that school and that curriculum
to their country so
34 school in as many countries uh
nearly there's a three or four in france
um
opening really this new type of
education
and the good news is uh just now i just
find out we are
we did our three months of selection uh
we've just selected 106 students in
their new cohort
41 are women
41 and no positive discrimination
so it shows as well that that what we've
done is we bought people like you
people young women to talk to our
students at kodam
well thank you it's worked it inspired
other women
and now we've got 41 percent of women
it's a bit of a scoop because i just got
a minute the
the numbers two minutes ago uh and i'm
so proud of the team
and of all of you that helped us inspire
young women
to join kodam and uh and again
completely blind selection so no
positive discrimination
41 of women in the next kodam cohort
well corrine that's amazing to hear uh
actually the
this um like a couple of months ago i
had an intern um
from kodam and uh he was very passionate
and he was really
enthusiastic about learning machine
learning and data science which actually
inspired me and i've learned from him a
lot it was like
it should it should have been the other
way around but i i've learned a lot from
him as well
um i wanted to ask you about because
most of our audience are data scientists
and people who are
working in data science field i want to
ask you
what role codem plays in in data science
field and
is there any programs in place to
encourage students or
does the student show interest to
join this field of data science machine
learning
yes absolutely i think you can again
you don't know what you don't know so
those students their world
is getting bigger by you people coming
to talk to them about your jobs what you
do on a daily basis we encourage
or student to use open source software
um
they deposit their software on github
and the advantage is when they go
somewhere someone can just have a look
at their code
and understand the code it's uh they can
read it they can understand it so
i think this i think you know in the
future and you see it also the way we
recruit
you don't gonna if you recruit a
software engineer you're not gonna
really look at their cvs or where
they've gone
you're gonna look at their code and you
look at what they've been using where
they find the information the quality of
the code
how they got to solve the problems so i
think this is uh
yeah i'm a big fan and uh and codam is
definitely encouraging that
to get people to work on projects using
open source software
okay that's that that's great and that's
very
nice so um uh my question and my next
question is that how open source
community
can learn from kodam and its philosophy
the way you are
you are educating these students well i
think the open source community is
already a community of people
contributing to
to uh to something whatever the world
it's a community based on so everybody
is
is using um software contributing back
to it and i think the philosophy of
kodam is the same
we we want people to learn with each
other to
solve problems with each other to to
actually contribute to that
to that community in the same way we
encourage them to do that
and i think that's uh that's the future
of of technology and that's
it's the problem we're solving are so
complex that
if everybody all over the world are
contributing to uh
to a core and i think to see what
happened with with linux and
and other big uh big platforms i think
that's uh that's definitely the future
and i uh
i would uh i would encourage that again
it's not my area of expertise
but i can see the benefit of it and
that's something we definitely
uh encourage in our in our student
community
and i think that's uh you can see the
popularity of open source software
i think it's
uh to open source how do you think that
it's going to change in future in your
opinion
yeah again i think education needs to to
change
anyway i i think the the web for what
i've said earlier as well
the way we are organized the way we're
teaching kids we are not rewarding the
right things we're not rewarding
creative thinking we're not rewarding
uh leadership skills so we all those
soft skills
are so important and you can see that
yourself in your work environment
so i think to encourage people to be
curious to look at what's available
it's not going to be inventing the wheel
look at the tools look at what's
available look at what's been done
already
use that and then contribute to that i
think
everybody can build on each other's
efforts i think that's the future that
would help us
accelerate uh discovery progress and
innovation
uh and i think we're all gonna you know
the community
works with each other using uh open
source software
uh i'm hoping that this will accelerate
innovation
and make uh yeah and get us to where we
solving those really big issues we're
facing much faster and in a much more
open way
yeah that's that's true i completely
agree with you um
so as i i guess as last question
i wanted to ask you what advice do you
give to
um to our audience to uh young
professions or even
people who are starting uh learning
programming how they navigate through
this uh
through the tech world i know that
sometimes it can be intimidating for
people who are
um who are not who don't uh who doesn't
have the background
uh and uh it's just uh you know a
holding them back
to step up in this world what what
advices do you give to them
well first of all it's never too late to
learn so if i look at kodam and we get
uh people that come from uh that
and with killing it is something that
that's very important today and there
are a lot of ways of learning
i would say to people invest in yourself
it's not it's not too late to learn
try to have a look at the the areas
that that you interested in i'm always a
great big believer
that if you do something that you
believe in or you work for
a company that does something you
believe in or with the team
which you get the energy because there
is a good team dynamic
that that's that's the first thing so i
would say try it and learn a lot about
yourself
not easy when you're 20 you accept that
you actually don't know
much about yourself try to analyze uh
when you've had a good day
when you've had a bad day what do you
think you really the type of people you
really want to work with and you really
don't want to work with
and try to have this as a a bit of the
northern stars or where you want to go
and as of technologies as far as
technology is concerned
there are a lot of uh courses out there
some like kodam which is a bit long two
or three years
but you also have boot camps just try to
uh
keep yourself current don't hesitate to
invest in yourself and your knowledge if
you join if you want to go into
into the technology field the it is
unlikely you will
not find a job if you're in technology
we have
crying out for people the shortage of
software engineers data scientists
but also marketeer online marketers and
growth hackers if you look at the whole
technology spectrum
is huge so i would advise people to to
look in this area
talk to people who are doing those jobs
some of those jobs didn't exist five
years ago
so it's very difficult to to know so i
would advise to find people on linkedin
or find mentoring platform or people say
hey what it is that you do have looked
at it it sounds really interesting can
you tell me more so
uh be bold uh try to engage
talk to people and uh try to get a good
idea of the
of of all the opportunities that are out
there
there are many there are many jobs there
are many opportunities to change the
world a little bit
in an area that you're passionate about
just go for it
yeah that's actually i can i totally
relate to that
i think i've known most of the people
who are who helped me actually in my
career in my education in
in in places that i've never thought
about the event that i hesitated to go
a community that i hesitated to
contribute so that's actually true that
you you you see the opportunities where
you never imagined that you um you're
gonna just jump from there
that's that's uh i totally relate to
that um i wanna just check
next time i need to interview you oh
okay yeah and that would be my honor
but yeah i'm gonna talk long so you have
to stop me then maybe 30 minutes is not
it's not going to be enough for
that interview um so i'm going to just
check if you have
any questions left
uh otherwise then we can um yeah
so basically we have it um we have
platforms i think people can ask
questions then if it's okay then uh if
there are questions then i can
uh ask you briefly um if uh there are
then
then we can um you can send them to me
and then we can we can do it
and next time of course okay okay
then yeah yeah i will keep keep that in
mind
thank you so much korean for joining us
it was uh an honor to talk to you and to
have you here
thank you so much again take care
everyone good luck bye-bye
and i will give this stage to um our
other host and our
other speaker enjoy
you